Her low freak bitches.
Yeah,
I worry about that constantly.
I mean with the Oscar mix up last night,
I mean,
I heard about that,
see it,
but I heard about it.
I mean,
what did they mix up my eggs?
What's,
what happened?
They said someone one and then it turned out to be someone,
Warren Beatty.
They gave him an envelope.
Bless his heart.
I can't and I'm so hard not read anymore.
No,
it's,
they gave him the wrong envelope.
Warren Beatty has done nothing except be a classy legend.
She was just like the Steve Harvey thing.
Same thing,
same thing.
All the memes are,
are uh,
the comparing them basically like,
you know,
Warren Beatty's and new Steve Harvey or Warren Beatty's of brilliant legend.
And Steve Harvey is a silly talk show hosts.
Um,
but uh,
but yeah,
he,
he got the envelope for best actress and he's so,
and he's just saw La la land and said best.
Uh,
and the entire cast of La la land went up on stage and then they had to go,
oh,
actually it's moonlight.
And then when the producers of La La land was a total class act and gentlemen
and was like,
Moonlight won,
and then moonlight had to come up.
It was math.
It was like the super bowl stress level.
I fucking hate those contests.
I don't have a dog in the game.
What was it?
What's the dog in the fight dog in the fight.
I don't have a dog in the fight,
but I hate those.
I hate award shows from there.
Seems so pretentious.
If you're not already won,
you have,
you've all won millions of dollars.
Movie Stars.
What is the,
well,
I think for me,
I mean especially with like the political climate,
when people go and make political speeches,
it's like,
okay,
how much did you donate this year?
Like what are you really do?
Like,
you know,
just making all these speeches and talking to talk.
I hope everyone's also walking the walk and you know,
authentic that way.
I don't know,
it's just,
it's so,
I mean I think loaded,
there's something anesthetic about it for people.
I think there's,
look at the silly monkey,
like the diversion of dresses and necklaces and makeup and actresses.
You know,
I think humans,
we have probably been an inherent need for that sort of diversion,
that sort of,
um,
uh,
vapid.
Let's talk about dresses instead of what's really going on.
And there's always a ribbon.
Does your,
that you're supposed to wear.
Yup.
What was the ribbon they had to wear last night?
Wasn't a blue,
what was it for
you?
I thought it was for the iceberg that was breaking off.
They're worried about that giant iceberg.
The size of Manhattan.
Fucking,
I know.
It's just,
it's just,
there's so many,
you know,
and I just get frustrated sometimes.
I mean,
your,
your listeners are not the ones,
cause your listeners seem to all be seekers.
Like who the fuck knows?
It's like saying all girls or all boys,
I know my listeners or there's a bunch of men met Maggie.
One that listens to you is smart,
I think,
or at least aspires to be.
I believe in you guys.
Where's Kendall Jones?
Who
thongs
should be lion hunting porn?
You shoot and you fuck right on top of this.
I feel like that would do well.
The guy,
Jesus,
someone very desensitized.
Um,
I mean that's what it's coming to level I guess these days.
Hashtag read it.
Um,
but yeah,
I'm sure it's humans have a need to uh,
just sort of disassociate with,
you know,
pictures of dresses.
Yeah,
I think there's definitely some of that.
there's definitely the pageantry people love when people dress up in all their
best and they walked real love watching people.
Oh yeah.
I'll try to keep it together.
Look at that fake clap.
Yeah.
Look,
oh she's not even happy for,
it's like,
well no matter what she does,
you're going to project your shit onto this.
But you know what I do?
I do secretly not so secretly enjoy what I do.
Enjoy watching people as they get older who are clearly fucking crazy.
Keep it together.
Less and less.
Nicole Kidman was crapping like the Grinch last night clubs.
Yes.
She was clapping.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know what that is.
I don't clap a lot cause we're comics.
We don't go to shows.
I don't even know it.
Clap.
Well,
uh,
you have to clap if you have a daughter that's in a play.
Oh,
constantly.
But are you all just filming the whole time?
No,
I clap my wife films.
Yeah.
A clap.
I don't like,
I'm not a good clapper either.
I do it after sac clap when you got a job.
Yay.
Hounded out.
Look at her.
Look at it.
No Way.
Look at this.
She also has,
she's comically Willoway.
I mean,
she does.
Her nails went,
I don't know.
There's something crazy going carpal tunnel.
She,
she's pulling her hands way back.
That's not,
she's doing too much.
Be crumb.
That's not good for your joints.
Okay.